it was just last week that I was making
the case that Betsy DeVos as Secretary
of Education for Donald Trump is the
least qualified member of his cabinet
and I asked the audience write to me if
you can think of someone less qualified
than Betsy DeVos and basically no one
disagreed with me people you said hey
there are people as unqualified as Betsy
DeVos but there's no one more
unqualified than Betsy DeVos and this
happens to now beyond the heels of us
having the special pleasure of Betsy
DeVos completely face-planting in a
totally cringe-worthy manner during a
number of interviews including one on 60
minutes with Lesley Stahl I happen to
know one of Leslie Stahl's producers and
let's just say all aspects of this
interview were a total mess she couldn't
answer even the simplest questions about
anything and I worry as I mentioned
earlier in the show that we're sort of
so desensitized to the insanity of the
current administration that we won't
even realize how tragic this is but it's
very tragic take a look at this first
clip the public schools in Michigan
gotten better I don't know overall I
can't say overall that they have all
gotten better the whole state is not
doing well well there are certainly lots
of pockets where the students are doing
well have you seen the really bad
schools maybe try to figure out what
what they're doing I have not I have not
I've not intentionally visited schools
that are underperforming maybe you
should maybe I should yes maybe I should
so she has no idea how Michigan schools
are doing she hasn't gone to the
struggling schools and it continues she
also did an interview on NBC's Today
Show where she had no idea how to answer
questions about the entire school safety
thing and remember she's wanted to arm
teachers for a while Trump who she works
for wants to arm teachers she bailed on
a press conference last week in Florida
when she was asked specific questions
about school safety and arming teachers
you've got to assume when you do another
interview you're gonna be asked about
that again and then again she has just
no clue about it do you think they
should be able teacher should be able to
carry assault weapons since presumably
they may face assault weapons do you
have an opinion on that
I don't think an assault weapons in
schools of carried by any school
personnel is the appropriate thing but
again this is an issue that I think is
best decided at the local level by
communities and by state but wait now it
should be decided at the local level you
wanted to arm teachers the president is
talking about arming teachers who you
work for and now all of a sudden you
have no opinion and it should be up to
the local schools and fortunately there
was follow-up to that one but a student
could legally carry an assault weapon a
student over 18 not in school not in
schools they can't okay so you still
want the schools to be gun-free zones
except for the teachers I think schools
have to be protected like every other
large gathering place well one of the
ways that we protect large gathering
places is that guns aren't allowed and
they are the gun-free zones that I
thought you and Trump were actually
against just one bizarre answer after
another and congressman ted Lieu had a
hilarious tweet pointing out that these
weren't really tough questions
he tweeted Betsy DeVos wasn't asked what
is the airspeed velocity of an unladen
swallow she was asked basic questions
about education and had trouble
answering them why are we shocked about
this right the reason she can't put
together a coherent argument is that she
doesn't care she doesn't care she is
someone who became incredibly rich
through an amway pyramid scheme who
doesn't even like public education sends
her kids to private school and somehow
someone has decided she should be in
charge of the Secretary of the
Department of Education oh right that
someone is Donald Trump just disgusting